Most movie audiences head to the theater to
see a story exactly as its told, without looking
too closely at the plots, characters, or lines
of dialogue. But for the diehard fans always
searching for added meaning, some twists,
names, or confusing quotes can make even a
classic movie twice as much fun to watch.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Hidden Messages
in Popular Movies.
The Matrix
There's plenty of symbolism in this sci-fi
series, but younger fans probably missed one
clever reference. When Neo has gone as far
down the rabbit hole as possible, and is fleeing
from enemy agents, he makes a strange demand
of his operator outside of the system. The
line is lifted from an old cartoon series
starring Tooter Turtle, whose adventures in
different time periods would always go wrong
- only his friend, Mr. Wizard could save the
day. Apparently the show also existed in the
Matrix's artificial reality. Either that,
or Keanu Reeves felt a kinship with the monotone
turtle.
Jurassic Park
It's hard to believe Jurassic Park was originally
NOT going to use CG dinosaurs, but Steven
Spielberg spent months working with stop motion
guru Phil Tippett to create his dinosaurs
with the same technique used to bring the
Imperial Walkers and Tauntauns to life in
The Empire Strikes Back. When the director
asked ILM to show him what a computerized
dinosaur could look like, the decision was
clear. When Tippett learned he'd been beaten
out by newer tech, he told the director that
"he'd just became extinct." Luckily, that
wasn't the case - but Spielberg made sure
to put that very line into the movie.
Jackie Brown
Every fan of Quentin Tarantino knows that
the director likes to connect his films into
one universe, with characters living in the
same world, or some films existing as movies
for those characters to see in a theater.
But what about a movie that reveals it's just
a movie in its own story?
That's what some fans claim about Jackie Brown.
When a character walks out of a movie theater
to the sound of its credits score, the music
is what's expected of Tarantino. But viewers
will eventually realize that it's the same
music that plays over the movie's own end
credits. A shared universe wasn't enough:
the director had to hint that Jackie Brown
was already playing in theaters while the
cast was still living through it.
Die Hard
Now known as one of the greatest action movies
of all time, it's easy to forget the softer
side of hero John McClane. When the New York
cop flies to Los Angeles to spend Christmas
with his family, he brings a gift with him:
a large stuffed bear, complete with a red
ribbon tied around its neck. If the movie
followed the novel it was based on, that bear
should have made it to John's daughter, but
director John McTiernan never got to show
that scene. Apparently, nothing said fatherly
love to the director like a teddy bear, since
his next movie The Hunt For Red October doubled
down on the idea. When Jack Ryan had saved
the day and headed home to his wife and daughter,
he did what any good dad would do: picked
up a teddy bear f his own, red ribbon and
all.
Dodgeball: A True Underdog Story
It doesn't usually pay to look below the surface
of a movie based on grown men getting hit
in the face with inflatable balls, but this
is one exception. When the team at Average
Joe's Gym goes up against the cocky, well-funded,
testosterone-fuelled Purple Cobras, it's a
battle of David vs. Goliath. But viewers might
not realize that seeing the "Joes" vs. "Cobra"
is one big nod to G.I. Joe and their greatest
enemies. With that in mind, audiences should
have realized that the Joes would always come
out on top.
Harry Potter
A good witch or wizard needs a trusty pet,
and for Harry Potter, Hedwig the Owl went
above and beyond the call of duty. The bird's
dedication to the boy wizard made her a hit
with fans, and broke their hearts when she
sacrificed her life to protect Harry. A righteous
death for the boy she loved should have been
expected. In the books, Hedwig takes her name
from a medieval witch or wizard. But in the
real world, Hedwig is the patron saint of
orphaned and abandoned children - making her
the perfect guardian for the movie's hero.
Ant Man
Marvel's Avengers universe is based on fantastic
figures, science, and otherworldly adventures,
but they're apparently even hard to believe
for the everyday characters inside the films
themselves. When Ant-Man villain Darren Cross
references the old stories of a miniature
superhero working in secret, he claims they're
nothing but "propaganda, Tales to Astonish."
He's not wrong, either. Ant-Man's unbelievable
powers actually debuted in the comic "Tales
to Astonish", making this one of the most
meta moments Marvel has included, and a major
statement about the hero's entire story for
the viewers who manage to catch it.
Ferris Bueller's Day Off
Director John Hughes had a knack for churning
out classic movies in the 1980s, and decided
to remind audiences of that fact in as subtle
a way as possible. The license plate of Cameron's
father's Ferrari reading "nervous" fits his
character, but it's the rest of the cars that
deliver the nods to the director's previous
movies: the plate on Ferris' mother's car
refers to Vacation which he wrote, his dad's
to Mr. Mom, and the principal's plate clearly
made for Ferris Bueller's Day Off.
Avatar
From the moment Avatar hit theaters, it was
clear that James Cameron had filled the movie
with tons of political messages. From deforestation,
over-aggressive military, to the destruction
of Native peoples and the discovery of the
New World - you name it. It didn't take long
for people to notice that there was one country
in particular that the director was singling
out. When the movie's villain is explaining
the risks of the planet to his new recruits,
it's hard to miss the stripes of the American
flag shining behind him - once you see it,
it's not even that subtle.
The Matrix
Aside from pop culture references, the Wachowskis
also managed to include one massive hint that
most fans probably never noticed. When Neo
finally confronts the Architect of the Matrix
in the first sequel, he learns that the creator
of the system has been following him his entire
life (or lives) - and the first movie already
offered proof. When Neo is first captured
by enemy Agents, a bank of surveillance monitors
shows him being interrogated. The exact same
monitors the Architect is surrounded by in
the next movie. Critics may claim the directors
never planned on more than one film to start,
but some of the bigger ideas were clearly
there right from the start.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any hidden messages or secret
meanings in your favorite films?
Be sure to share them in the comments, and
subscribe to our YouTube channel if you want
more great Movie and TV easter eggs, hidden
clues, mistakes and fun facts!